activists have started protesting Donald
Trump staffers and cabinet members I
told you last week about Department of
Homeland Security Secretary Kerstin
Nielsen who was heckled at a Mexican
restaurant by protesters later active it
not later the same day but later in the
week er earlier this week more
protesters showed up at her house and
had speakers playing audio of migrant
children crying at the border as they
were being separated from their parents
Trump's completely loony advisor Stephen
Miller was heckled at a different
Mexican restaurant Sara Huckabee Sanders
was asked to leave a restaurant in
Virginia this is not violence of any
kind this is legal and still there are
people who have a problem with it even
Pat actually has said that he sort of
has a problem with it as he said earlier
this week there are people saying we
must be activists but we must at all
times remain completely civil I want to
give you a little context about that
idea Cooney professor and historian
Angus Johnston found some articles from
the New York Times from 1934 okay and
the articles were by a Quaker named
Henry Cadbury
and Henry Cadbury didn't like the
conflict that was taking place between
Jews and Nazis so he wrote an article
urging goodwill by Jews for the Nazis
and the argument that was being made at
the time was that the resistance of the
Nazis by Jews is just going to make
things even worse for everyone folks
know just know this is not going to work
Trump is about to appoint a Supreme
Court justice that could repeal roe v
wade and set off a chain reaction of up
to 20 states that will ban abortion
period this is not the time for signing
petitions posting flyers and making
phone calls this is the time for action
and I'm not saying violence someone
called in last week and said hey David
what what do you think about an Tifa
burning down the child internment camps
as a form of protest and I said well no
first of all there would be kids inside
why would you burn down the place with
the kid
if we're trying to protect the kids but
I'm not saying violence I am saying the
shaming and the taking up a notch of
these public embarrassment campaigns of
these individuals when people and our
basic societal institutions are under
attack expressing outrage is the right
thing to do and making the people
responsible for carrying the policies
out uncomfortable is your duty never
mind
something that is acceptable don't do it
in a counterproductive way right if 20
years from now though the atour the the
authoritarian slide has become
institutionalized legal authoritarianism
and abortion is banned and same-sex
marriage is somehow repealed and
corporate power is given even more of a
foothold as a result of the Supreme
Court are you going to be satisfied that
you called up your representative and
you said hey message for Elizabeth
Warren's office please oppose Donald
Trump's nominee is that going to be
enough for you to feel like you did
everything you could I know that I
wouldn't Pat and I know that there are
many people in the audience who wouldn't
feel like they did enough either and the
problem is that in many societies
violence is allowed only top down those
in power can inflict violence on others
law enforcement at the border the
Supreme Court on women by banning
abortion or whatever other policy soon
as it goes the other way it's a big
problem I mean there's an example look
at what the forces of power did about
some football players silently kneeling
during the national anthem so we know
that top-down political violence is
acceptable as soon as you try to reverse
it things get real very very quickly so
the understanding that we have to have
is that there might be arrests and there
might be trouble and it's going to come
down to how willing are we to fight for
what we know is right remember when we
were saying that the Democrats should
shut down the Senate until Merrick
garland gets confirmed that didn't
happen and this is why it matters
because now Trump got Yael Gorsuch and
now Trump gets to replace Anthony
Kennedy and this is why the calls for
civility from those in power who
have a lot to lose if people realize how
outraged they should actually be are
hypocritical and they should be ignored
and there's a choice to make okay we can
say I'll live my life I'll try to take a
vacation when I can afford it I'll go to
the movies I'll play a video game I'll
read a book I'll learn the ins and outs
of vegan cooking whatever right and wait
for it to go away before you know it
what might have gone away are not the
problems but the foundations of our
society that you take for granted while
you sit there and read your book if that
book is even even still allowed right
because that's also not a guarantee if
you're with me let's work together to
figure out how to fight this stuff we've
got to do more than just write letters
to members of Congress I applaud the
people who are coming up with new ideas
who have been reaching out to me and in
the mat background you've got to support
independent media right because there is
a three-pronged attack on independent
progressive media and if we don't
survive I don't know what we'll have
left because you're not going to have
corporate media and you're barely gonna
have the internet with the net
neutrality repeal let's brainstorm
together what we can do I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll take a quick break and
be back after this today's program is
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to better help
calm slash Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you you
can change therapists if you don't think
that it's a good fit it's less expensive
than seeing someone in person you will
still get the professional help and it
is unlimited you can talk to a therapist
every day from home or wherever you are
go to better help calm slash Pakman it
is so easy to sign up and get started
we've put a link in the description if
you're watching on YouTube
better how
calm /pa que ma n if you've been wanting
to talk to somebody but for whatever
reason haven't please go to better help
calm /pa que ma n